en su camino hacia la carrera
presidencial Mike pence ha lanzado
oficialmente su nombre alrededor como
candidato republicano para las
elecciones presidenciales de 2024 el
político de 63 años presentó la
documentación que declara su campaña y
se espera un anuncio formal el miércoles
en Iowa
tengo que decirles que Durante los
últimos dos años Karen y yo hemos pasado
mucho tiempo reflexionando y llorando
sobre todo lo que está pasando en este
país y lo que podríamos hacer para
servir y no tengo nada que anunciar hoy
pero puedo decirles Cuando tenga tiempo
para anunciar este miércoles lo
anunciaré en Iowa
su mayor rival por supuesto será Donald
Trump quien fue su jefe cuando se
desempeñó como vicepresidente entre 2017
y 2021 pens fue un fiel defensor del
presidente durante esos cuatro años pero
se ha distanciado desde el asalto de Los
partidarios de Trump al Capitolio de los
Estados Unidos en enero de 2021 Trump
había presionado a pense para anular la
victoria electoral de Joe biden algo a
lo que él se negó Durante los hechos
algunos manifestantes pedían colgar a
pence mientras asaltaban los pasillos
del Congreso por lo que muchos
seguidores de Trump lo ven como un
traidor pence es solo otro nombre para
agregar a una lista cada vez mayor de
candidatos republicanos Allí se incluye
al gobernador de Florida ron de santis
quien has visto como el contendiente más
cercano de Trump así como la
exgobernadora de Carolina del Sur Nicky
Haley muchos expertos describen Esta
carrera por la nominación republicana
como una de las más derechistas que ha
visto el partido
[Aplausos]